bonjour
vous avez devant vous un militaire un
officier de marine est aussi un pilote
de chasse embarqués sur porte-avions
alors vous vous dites un militaire
c'est du sérieux c'est du solide ça se
fait obéir ça donne des ordres
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à être militaire
c'est d'abord savoir se battre se battre
contre les nuits évidemment mais c'est
aussi savoir se battre contre soi même
contre ses peurs contre ses limites
contre ses doutes contre le
découragement
et puis c'est aussi savoir se battre
avec son équipe avec son équipage contre
la fatalité du destin
l'amiral stock d'elle un pilote de
chasse américains qui étaient abattus
dans la guerre du vietnam a passé huit
ans de détention
hanoi dans une prison qui s'appelait le
panneau hilton il y a été torturé à
plusieurs reprises et dans ses mémoires
il raconte que les premiers de ses
camarades qui sont morts c'étaient les
pessimistes les pessimistes pensait
qu'ils étaient en captivité et que tout
était foutu et du coup ils ne se
battaient pas
et de manière étonnante
ceux qui sont morts juste après c'était
les optimistes les optimistes se disait
on va être libérée il attendait noël à
pâques ils n'étaient pas libérés et en
juin il était mort parce qu'ils ne
s'étaient pas battus
pour vivre pour survivre il faut se
battre il faut se battre au quotidien
one day one fight
et finalement la défaite ce n'est que
l'issue d'un combat qu'on n'a pas livré
alors je vais vous raconter deux
histoires
deux immersion de combat
première immersion
appontages de nuit sur un porte-avions
alors ça commence comme sur la photo par
un catapultages
et une mission opérationnelle de
plusieurs heures
au dessus de la mer ou au dessus de la
terre et puis du ravitaillement en vol
et un retour en holt attitude avec un
équipier
voler de nuit sur un porte-avion c'est
absolument fabuleux
au dessus de la nuit à des nuages un
firmament des toiles on se croirait dans
une cathédrale et on se prendrait
presque pour un cosmonaute
mais en dessous des nuages quand on
descend vers la mer
c'est le noir absolu il n'y a plus
aucune référence
c'est comme dans une cave et piloter un
avion de chasse dans une cave c'est
compliqué
il faut faire confiance à ces
instruments à sa planche de bord et puis
à cette petite ligne verte qui sert
d'horizon artificielle dans son viseur
c'est le fil d'ariane qui va faire
revenir à bas
alors il faut quitter les étoiles et
plonger vers le noir plonger vers le
porte-avions
une piste à terre c'est 3 km 80 m de
large c'est très bien éclairé il ya des
lumières partout
il ya la ville qui est pas très loin et
donc c'est pas si compliqué que ça
celle du porte-avions elle fait 200 m de
long 30 m de large le bateau avance
parfois il bouge à l'est faiblement
éclairé par ce que il faut pas être
ébloui dans le noir absolu
alors revenir vers un porte avions ça se
fait pas comme une piste on peut pas
freiner pour se poser il faut attraper
un câble d'acier avec un crochet qui est
sous le ventre de l'avion une crosse qui
va attraper un des trois câbles qui est
à l'arrière du bateau et qui va servir à
freiner l'avion avant qu'il retombe au
bout de la piste à la vitesse d'approché
de l'avion la crosse survolent la zone
des 3 brins en un tiers de seconde
alors c'est compliqué
c'est difficile c'est d'ailleurs
tellement difficile qu'il faut être
aidés alors à l'arrière du bateau dans
le noir aussi un ancien pilote
l'officier d'appontage va donner des
conseils assurer la sécurité et puis il
va aussi vous notez
la technique pour revenir sur le bateau
c'est un mélange assez subtil entre de
la très haute technicité et du lâcher
prise
la haute technicité parce qu'il faut
être extrêmement précis il faut piloter
son avion comme une horloge au point qu
on se prendrait comme un robot en train
d'exécuter un logiciel la vitesse aux
noeuds près la descente au dixième de
degré près le cap ou demi degré près
et puis de l'autre
les émotions là le noir le sentiment
oppressant oppressant de cette obscurité
dans lequel il n'y a pas de référence
la complexité de la tâche la pression du
résultat le fait que pour raconter les
réserves de carburant sont faibles parce
que la masse maximale de l'avion ne
supporte pas beaucoup de réserves ça
veut dire que si on rate on n'a pas
beaucoup de chance on a une ou deux
tentatives supplémentaires sinon il faut
se dérouter ou aller faire le plein sur
une citerne volante
alors il faut dompter ses émotions
alors j'ai quitté les étoiles mon avion
est descendu vers la mer c'est tout noir
je suis à 20 km derrière le porte avions
je sors mon train je sors ma crosse
d'appontage et je me prépare
mon coeur bat la chamade je me dis que
ça va être difficile
alors il faut se détendre il faut se
déstresser
dans mes chaussures de pilotes
fait du piano avec mes doigts de pieds
pour me détendre
je me dis que j'ai été sélectionné que
j'étais entraîné et puis aussi qu'on va
m'aider il ya cette appli ces officiers
d'appontage qui est au bout du bateau
faire confiance à sa bonne étoile
alors mon avion commence à descendre
vers le porte avions un contrôleur
aérien me guide il égrène les caps les
altitudes
et puis à un moment il me fait son
annonce réglementaire hanautic 350 pieds
annoncé miroir mon avion est à 2 km à
l'arrière du porte-avions 100 mètres au
dessus de la surface des flots c'est à
moi de jouer
alors je fais aussi mon annonce
réglementaire
miroir 15 rock je vois des références de
la piste le petit tas de lumière sur
lequel il va falloir que je me pose
j'ai une tonne 5 de carburant et j'ai
donné mon nom de guerre
alors je commence une boucle de pilotage
de plus en plus fines il s'agit de
rester dans un cône virtuel qui au début
de la proche fait trente mètres de
diamètre et se réduit au moment où la
crosse va taper sur le pont ne veut plus
faire que 30 cm pour vous donner une
idée des choses c'est comme si avec
votre porsche vous passiez la barrière
du péage de l'autoroute dans le noir
total à 300 km heure avec juste une
petite lumière à gauche une petite
lumière à droite sur les parpaings en
béton
très concentré
les lumières se rapproche les
corrections sont de plus en plus fines
l'officier d'appontage donne un conseil
ferme lève le nez petite pression sur le
manche les lumières surgissent l'avion
tape sur le pont la crosse a
probablement accroché la manette des gaz
par sur l'avant au cas où cela serait
pas accroché et là je sens la
décélération mon corps ce temps dans les
bretelles
l'avion aval des quelques lumières de la
piste et s'arrête au bord du noir c'est
gagné
à bord
victoire sur soi
victoire aussi pour l'officier
d'appontage
deuxième l'immersion
cette fois c'est en océan indien le
commandent une frégate furtive on est
parti de toulon depuis quelques semaines
on a passé le canal de suez on descend
la mer rouge l'humeur est aventureuse on
part pour quatre mois et demi en océan
indien avec un équipage
il est 10 heures du matin je suis à la
passerelle et le pct des communications
me dit l'amiral qui commande les forces
de l'océan indien veut vous parler je
file au pc télécommunications sur le
téléphone satellite la mayral me dit des
pirates viennent de prendre d'assaut le
ponant un navire d'un voilier de
commerce il faut que vous alliez sauver
ces gens là foncez sur zone je raccroche
le téléphone le sourire aux oreilles on
me disant la baraka a trouvé son ami la
mission de ma vie va commencer
je remonte à la passerelle je demande au
chef de quart de sortir la carte pour
commencer à calculer le temps qu'il
faudra pour aller du détroit de bab el
mandeb à la pointe de la somalie au
moment précis où je plante le compas sur
ma carte pour calculer la distance le
bateau est pris de trépidation
incroyable le pupitre de la machine la
passerelle c'est un
j'entends la communication à folie du pc
machine qui me dit commandant on vient
de perdre la ligne d'arbre bâbord c'est
le grand axe dassier qui entraîne les
lys et qui par des moteurs
alors je laisse la manquons pas je file
au pc machine et là c'est la
consternation avec le chef de chaque
machine on descend dans le local de la
ligne d'arbre et là une apocalypse la
tôle et tordue et fumante l'électronique
de commande et de confettis et il ya de
l'hydraulique qui soit sur tous les murs
du local
remonte au pc machine tout le monde se
regarde tout le monde a compris que
c'était foutu
alors on rappelle l'amiral on lui
explique il pourra pas compter sur nous
je prends la diffusion générale jeudi
que la mission de quatre mois et demi
bien là en train de se terminer
et je vais tout seul dans ma chambre
méditez sur les fortunes du destin
et au cours de l'après-midi alors que je
n'ai rien demandé j'ai mon premier
maître donc un officier marinier
responsable du secteur propulsion qui
toquent à la porte
c'est pas n'importe qui ce gars-là c'est
un grand type assez rugueuse avec qui
les relations et depuis le début sont
pas faciles voilà une prend un peu de
haut moi je suis pilote et donc voilà je
fais pas partie de sa famille
et me dit commandant je pense qu'on peut
réparer
étonnement de l'ingénieur je me remémore
ce tas de tôles fumant cette
électronique en confettis et me demande
bien comme mon mécano va pouvoir me
proposer une solution alors je descends
au carré et je déroule avec le chef
machine les plans la ligne d'armes on y
passe l'après midi on a notre mécanos
qui nous explique qu'en coupant tel
machin en rebranchant tel autre truc on
va y arriver alors moi je suis très
incrédule je suis pilote de chasse et je
suis pas ingénieur en propulsion mais
finissent par me convaincre en fin
d'après midi je me décide à rappeler mon
amiral et donc je lui dis amiral on
pense qu'on peut réparer en 24 heures si
vous nous aidez on a besoin d'un
technicien
d'un peu de matériel et surtout on a
besoin que vous convainc kg et mon chef
à toulon qui lui est convaincu que c'est
foutu
l'amiral me répond enthousiaste j'ai
besoin de vous j'en fais mon affaire
je raccroche le téléphone est là dans le
bateau une bouffée d'oxygène vient
alimenter la petite lueur d'espoir qui
était né au milieu de l'après-midi
mais 30 mécano commence à s'affairer
comme une ruche j'ai même le capitaine
d'armes du bateau qui est un fusilier
commando qui s'improvisent dessinateur
en 3d pour faire des plans
d'intervention
lendemain matin à l'aube on arrive à
djibouti dans la nuit le matériel est
arrivé le technicien
alors commence
une opération difficile il fait très
chaud le local est extrêmement exigu
l'opération technique et complexe je
laisse les mécanos faire je me réfugie
au carré j'ai l'impression d'être un
papa qui attend l'accouchement son
premier enfant
les heures passent
et puis vers 15 heures mon premier
maître mais qu'à nous revient en disant
ça va le faire
je continue à attendre et vers 20 heures
le chef machine l'officier ans
responsable du de la propulsion vient me
voir et me dit commandant on peut partir
pour les essais
alors au milieu de la torpeur tropicale
de djibouti on largue les amarres et on
part dans la nuit faire les essais on
augmente la vitesse 12 noeuds 15 noeuds
17 non pas sur quatre moteurs monte à 24
noeuds la vitesse max du bateau on y
reste pendant une heure et ça tient ça
tient je reprends mon téléphone
j'appelle l'amiral et je lui dis amiral
pari tenu vous pouvez compter sur nous
raccroche le téléphone je donne les
ordres on repousse vers djibouti pour
récupérer du matériel des forces
spéciales des opérateurs du gign
on quitte dare-dare djibouti et on fonce
pendant trois jours à 24 noeuds vers la
somalie
la fortune de l'histoire fera qu'on
arrivera une demi-journée trop tard
entre temps d'autres bateaux ont
participé à la libération des otages et
mon bateau lui participera à la
rétention des pirates est là retour en
france mais ça c'est une autre histoire
le vrai combat ça a été celui de
l'équipage la fois le combat contre le
désespoir l'idée d'une solution la
mobilisation collective le combat contre
la fatalité
alors tout le monde croit que les
grandes choses sont le résultat de
grands combats
la réalité c'est que les grandes choses
sont le fruit de 1000 combat mille
combines un jour comme les deux que je
vous ai raconté
des petits combats des petites défaites
aussi parce que parfois on rate le brun
et on recommence et puis toutes les
pannes ne se répare pas facilement à la
mer mais vous aussi vous tous vous mener
chacun dans votre vie des petits combats
ce que je vous dis aujourd'hui c'est que
ce n'est pas parce que ça paraît
insurmontable que c'est un faisable
l'important c'est de se battre
avec lucidité avec persévérance
contre soi même avec son équipe one day
one night
[Applaudissements]